Ja.
Wir können anfangen.
Guten Abend, mein Name ist Hylian Inar. Ich bin als Assistenzärztin auf dieser Station tätig.
Heute werde ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Guten Abend, hallo.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen, danach kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden und Ihrer kranken Geschichte.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, sagen Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Okay. Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sabrina Heinrich.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachnamen und Vornamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Mein Vorname ist Sabrina. Siegfried Anton, B wie Bertha, R wie Richard, I wie Ida, N wie Nordpol und A wie Anton.
Heinrich ist der Nachname. A, Emil, Ida, Nordpol, Richard, Ida, Caesar, Heinrich.
Heinrich.
Frau Heinrich, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48 Jahre alt, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. April, 19...
23. April.
Ja, 23. April, 1978.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,72 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege ungefähr 86 Kilo.
86 und 80 Kilo.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Das ist der Herr Holz in der Bahnhofstraße.
Herr Holz in der Bahnhofstraße.
Frau Heinrich, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit gestern Abend zunehmende Engegefühl auf dem Brust und ein bisschen Luftnot.
Das kenne ich so gar nicht und das ist heute viel schlimmer geworden.
Engegefühl und Atemnot.
Ich merke, wenn ich eine kurze Strecke laufe, dass mir die Luft weg bleibt.
Bei Belastung, Treppensteigen?
Ja, das merke ich auch.
Haben Sie ein bisschen Beschwerde gehabt?
Früher, meinen Sie?
Ja, haben Sie früher ein bisschen Beschwerde gehabt?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe das erste Mal vorgestern.
Haben Sie?
Das kam ganz plötzlich.
Ganz plötzlich.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Kann ich so nicht sagen.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass mein Herz etwas schneller schlägt.
Seit wann? Seit gestern?
Das mit dem Herzen ist seit heute, merke ich. Aber nicht immer, nur manchmal.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
An sich nicht, also ganz leichte Schmerzen habe ich nicht, aber es war ein enger Gefühl.
Nur im oberen Brustbereich oder im ganzen Brustbereich?
Ja, der ganze Brustbereich glaube ich.
Es ist schwer einzuschätzen, aber es ist mehr die Luftnot, die mich beeinträchtigt.
Jetzt möchte ich das Ausnahmegespräch unterbrechen.
Ich möchte Ihnen Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ja, gerne.
Okay, ja, wir können weitermachen.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, Ihre Beine sind geschwollen?
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen Schmerzen am linken Bein, eher an der Wade.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wenn ich laufe, da zieht es ein bisschen und das wirkt auch ein bisschen gespannt.
Nur das linke Bein?
Ja, nur das linke Bein.
Geschwollen? Haben Sie in Ihren linken Beinen Rötung bemerkt?
Nein, also eine Rötung ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich merke schon, dass das etwas mehr geschwollener ist.
Und Schmerzen haben Sie in der Wade?
Ja.
Leichte Schmerzen.
In der Medizin benutzen wir eine Schmerzskala, wobei nur keine Schmerzen sind, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen auf dieser Skala?
Auf welcher Skala?
Nummerliche Ratingskala. Nur keine Schmerzen, sondern sehr starke Schmerzen.
Also so stark sind sie noch nicht, aber ich würde sagen 3, 4 vielleicht.
3, 4. Okay.
Wie weit können Sie laufen? Wie viele Meter können Sie laufen?
Also schon nach 3, 4 Metern merke ich, dass die Luft knapp wird.
3, 4 Meter?
Ja, das sind schon nach einer kurzen Strecke.
Wie gesagt, gestern war es noch nicht so schlimm, aber heute ist es schon sehr bemerkbar.
Okay.
Deswegen bin ich gekommen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Na, Heinrich, haben Sie Taubsheitgefühl, Kribben in der linken Bein?
Nein.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden? Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Ich werde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem Allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stürmen?
Nein, bisher nicht. Also ich war bisher nie krank.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stürmfrost?
Nein, auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Apathie?
Eigentlich ganz gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich habe es seit gestern nicht so gut.
Da habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich schlecht Luft bekomme, wenn ich mich hinlege.
Ich verstehe.
Und, ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig? Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen, nein.
Oder erbrechen?
Nein, erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen, z.B. Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, also bisher war jetzt nichts.
Ich bin alle paar Jahre bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der macht auch immer ein Checkup.
Bisher war eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Der Blutdruck war in Ordnung.
Die Laborwerte waren in Ordnung.
Da war jetzt nichts aufregiges.
Ja, ich freue mich, das zu hören.
Leben Sie Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Sind Sie gesund, Ihre Eltern?
Ich sage mal so, sie sind sehr fit.
Aber mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck.
Der nimmt Medikamente ein.
Meine Mutter hat einen leichten Parkinson.
Aber mit Medikamenten kommt sie gut zurecht.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente?
Ich bin seit zwei Jahren in der Menopause.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen.
Meine Frauenärztin hat mir Hormone gegeben.
Und danach geht es mir besser.
Seitdem fühle ich mich besser.
Sonst habe ich keine anderen Tabletten.
Kennen Sie diese Medikamente?
Den Namen?
Tut mir leid, jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie die heißen.
Hormone Medikamente.
Herr Heinrich?
Frau Heinrich.
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Oh, nicht viele. 4-5 Stück am Tag, mehr nicht.
Seit wann?
Schon seit 30 Jahren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr sehr selten.
Was meinen Sie, einmal pro Woche, einmal pro Monat?
Nein, ich trinke eigentlich überhaupt keinen Alkohol.
Nur beim Geburtstagsfest vielleicht oder wenn eine Feier ist.
So ein kleines Sekt Glas.
Sonst aber nicht.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Ja, gegen Pollen.
Aber ansonsten habe ich keine anderen Allergien.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Ja, meine Nase läuft, meine Augen tränen.
Da nehme ich aber Cetirizin und das hilft mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie Cetrisin?
Ja, wenn die Pollenallergie beginnt.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, wir waren jetzt drei Wochen lang in Singapur.
Und sind erst auch vorgestern zurückgekehrt.
Das war auch eine lange Reise, ein langer Flug.
Aber das war alles sehr schön.
Wie lange dauert der Flug?
Fast zehn Stunden.
Das war schon ein sehr langer Flug.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, mein Hausarzt meinte, die Impfungen sind komplett.
Wir haben auch vor der Reise die ganzen Impfungen kontrollieren lassen.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Frau Heinrichmann, ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit gestern bestehende Zunehmende,
enge Gefühle und Atemnot.
Besonders treten diese Beschwerden bei Belastung auf.
Sie haben Herzrasen seit heute.
Ihr linker Bein ist geschwollen und keine Beton.
Die linke Wade ist geschwollen.
Sie haben keine anderen Beschwerden.
Vielen Dank für den Gespräch.
Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das war es eigentlich. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Angst, was es ist, weil es so plötzlich aufgetrieben ist.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen. Ich hoffe, Sie finden heraus.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Zuerst werde ich Ihnen körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich Ihnen Laboruntersuchungen...
Das heißt, Sie werden mir Blut abnehmen?
Ja, Blut abnehmen und andere Verfahren durchführen.
Was wollen Sie noch machen?
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus gekommen, weil ich von meinen Nachbarn gehört habe,
dass Sie sehr gut ausgestattet sind und gute Geräte und gute Ärzte hier im Haus haben.
Ja, im Krankenhaus gibt es gute Ärzte und technologische Möglichkeiten.
Okay, deswegen bin ich da. Ich hoffe, Sie finden bald heraus, was es ist.
Setzen Sie sich in die Untersuchung. Ich komme gleich.
Okay, wunderbar. Vielen Dank.
Danke auch.
Hat jemand noch Fragen an unsere Patienten? Ja, bitte stellen Sie Ihre Frage, Herr Dschang.
Vielleicht muss man das Mikrofon lösen, Herr Ayartar. Sie sind der Admin, glaube ich.
Hallo.
Ich habe eine Frage stellen.
Bitte schön.
Ist Ihre Waden Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, ja seit gestern.
Plötzlich.
Ich sage, das war ja die Reise, der Flug, das war alles in Ordnung. Da haben wir überhaupt keine Probleme gehabt.
Kannst du das nicht stoppen?
Ja, so ein bisschen habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich heute ein bisschen Herzrasen habe.
Herzrasen, ja? Nicht stoppen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also das ist ein bisschen unregelmäßig. Ich habe das jetzt nicht genau gemessen, aber ich merke, dass es anders ist.
Danke.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Zunächst, Herr Dschang, ich brauche ein Riesengestell mal in den Geburtstag.
Das stimmt, ja. Vielen Dank.
Gerne. Ich habe ein paar Fragen, die sich heute beantwortet haben.
Operationen? Nein, habe ich keine.
Keine. Also haben Sie gestern etwas getrunken?
Was meinen Sie mit getrunken? Alkohol?
Noch mal bitte?
Was meinen Sie mit getrunken? Ich habe ganz normal Tee, meinen Kaffee.
Nein, Sie haben gesagt, bei der Geburtstagsparty oder Feiern...
Nein, nein, wir haben gestern keinen Geburtstag gefeiert. Ich bin erst gestern Abend zurückgekehrt von der Reise. Das machen wir nächste Woche, die Feier.
Ja, verstehe. Und letzte Mal, haben Sie Probleme besonders beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Beim Einatmen tue ich mir schwer.
Einatmen. Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte?
Sind die Schmerzen... Strahlen die Schmerzen in den Gateln aus?
Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden. Strahlen die Schmerzen?
Strahlen die Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen aus.
Von welchen Schmerzen sprechen Sie? Von den Waden?
Das enge Gefühl.
Das enge Gefühl? Nein, das ist auf der Brust. Das sieht nicht aus.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, bitte?
Bevor ich in die Beschwerden komme, hatten Sie Krampfaden?
Nein, bisher war da nichts bekannt.
Nichts bekannt.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, bitte?
Tritt die Atemnot nur bei Belastung oder auch in Ruhe auf?
Also in Ruhe ist noch alles okay. Nur wenn ich anfange zu laufen oder die Treppen steige, dann macht sich das sehr stark bemerkbar.
Und noch eine Frage. Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ich meine, Hochlagerung oder Tieflagerung des linken Beins.
Nein, da merke ich keinen Unterschied. Nein.
Danke.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Brustschmerzen eher beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Das ist dauerhaft. Da merke ich keinen Unterschied, was die Schmerzen angeht.
Ich merke aber, wenn ich mich belaste, dass das Einatmen mir schwer fällt.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich habe nicht gehört, aber Sie haben vielleicht keine Husten, oder?
Husten? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Und in letzter Zeit haben Sie in letzter Zeit Trauma oder Verletzung?
Verletzung? Nein.
Ach so, von einem Tier meinen Sie? Nein.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Nein, nein.
Konsumieren Sie die zusätzlichen Kräutern gegen Ihre wechselnde Schwerden?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur die Tabletten, die mir meine Frau erst verschrieben hat.
Aber Sie in den letzten Zeiten ungewohnt abzusuchen?
Nein, ich habe nur die Tabletten, die mir meine Frau erst verschrieben hat.
Nein, ich würde gerne abnehmen wollen, mit 86 Kilo.
Das ist ein bisschen viel, aber abgenommen habe ich nicht. Nein.
Aber Sie sind Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Sind Sie gesund oder haben Sie eine Krankheit?
Meine Schwester ist 5 Jahre jünger als ich und die ist gesund.
Ich habe bisher keine anderen Erkrankungen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen auf der linken Seite Schmerzen aufgefallen?
Auf welcher linken Seite?
Auf der linken Brust oder ...
Nein, nein.
Sartri?
Ja, bitte?
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Schlaganfall oder andere Erkrankungen?
Ich muss überlegen.
Nein, Verwandtschaft? Nein, das wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Nein.
Ist das linke Bein überwärmt?
Nein, die Frage war schon gestellt. Es ist nicht überwärmt und es ist auch nicht verfärbt.
Noch nicht.
Haben Sie keine Todesangst und kalte Schweiß, oder?
Noch nicht, nein.
Okay, danke.
Okay, ich glaube das war jetzt ausreichend.
Kommt noch eine Frage.
Ja, wann war Ihre letzte Regel? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die letzte Regel?
Ja, die letzte Regel.
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Okay.
Das hatte ich schon gesagt.
Ja, okay. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Verzeihung.
Dass ich Hormone wegen der Menopause nehme.
Okay, kommen noch Fragen oder sollen wir weitermachen, lieber Admin?
Frau Kollegin, wenn Sie bereit sind, dann können wir das Gespräch anfangen.
Okay.
Bitte.
Okay, ich warte.
Okay. Guten Abend, Herr Oberst. Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen. Dafür haben Sie dafür Zeit.
Aber natürlich, Frau Dr. Hülya, bitte schön. Wen haben Sie aufgenommen?
Es geht um Sabrina Heinrich.
Sabrina Heinrich, jawohl.
Frau Heinrich ist 48 Jahre alt und 86 Kilo schwer, 1,72 Meter groß.
Sie ist Lehrerin und hat zwei Kinder.
Frau Sabrina Heinrich, ich halte Sie heute wegen, seit gestern Abend, bestehende Zunahmende, Engelgefühl und Dispne bei uns vor.
Sie beschreiben diese Beschwerden plötzlich.
Plötzlich angefangen.
Dass die Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen haben oder ausgefunden sind, ja?
Ja. Und Sie berichteten oder klagten über am linken Waden Schwellung und Schmerzen.
Klagt über Schmerzen und Schwellung an der linken Wade.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 bis 4 von 10 auf der NRS. Sie berichteten darüber, dass Sie 3-4 Meter laufen können.
Sie haben nach 3-4 Metern Dispne.
Sie haben seit heute Herzrasen. Sie haben keine Brutschmerzen.
Sie berichteten besonders über Engelgefühl im ganzen Brustbereich.
Außerdem sagt sie, dass sie in Singapur war.
Sie ist vorgestern in Schützende geflogen.
Also sie hatte eine lange Reise hinter sich, ja?
Sie gab an, sie nehme Hormone wegen Menopose.
Sie rauche seit 30 Jahren 4-5 Zigaretten.
Also 3-4 Zigaretten am Tag.
Wie viele Packages sind das dann? Wie rechnet man das?
6.
Okay, das können wir dann nachher machen. Machen wir weiter. Wir fragen mal die anderen, wie man die Packages berechnet.
Sie trinken gelegentlich Alkohol. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie sind gegen Polen allergisch. Diese Allergie äußert sich Rhinokonjunktivitis.
Wie äußert sich mit einer Rhinokonjunktivitis?
Sie nehmen dagegen Cetrisin bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Die Fragen nach Problemen beim Wasserlassenstuhlgang, Fibre, Inapetens, Vertigo, Nausea, Emesis wurden verneint.
Aufgrund des Anamnesegesprächs gehe ich von tiefen Venen, Thrombose und
Und?
Und Lungenembolie.
Okay.
Ja, das könnte passen. Welche Untersuchungen machen Sie?
Zuerst werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen. Danach werde ich Ihnen Blutabnahme.
Ich werde ihr Blut abnehmen.
Und Thorex-Rotgenbild, Thorex-CT.
Welche Laborwerte wollen Sie wissen?
Blutbild, Däden, Laborwerte, Nierenwerte, Gerinnungsparameter.
Okay. Machen Sie auch einen Ultraschall?
Ja, besonders Wade, Dopplex, Ultrasonographie.
Okay, sehr gut.
Das werde ich durchführen.
Und welche Laborwerte machen Sie noch? Machen Sie auch die Blutgase?
Blutgase, ja. Sauerstoffsetigung, EKG.
EKG. Und was sieht man im EKG oder was erwarten Sie im EKG?
Wenn Sie eine Lungenembolie vermuten?
Ja, jetzt kann ich nicht erinnern.
Vielleicht können die Kolleginnen und Kollegen helfen.
Was sieht man manchmal im EKG, wenn jemand eine Lungenembolie akut bekommt?
Rechtsherz.
Rechtsherzbelastung, genau. Und als Folge der Rechtsherzbelastung erkennen Sie im EKG was?
Einen?
Langere P-A?
Ja, normales.
P1Q3C3 vielleicht?
Noch einfacher. Rechtschenkelblock.
Rechtschenkelblock.
Sie wissen alle was ein Rechtschenkelblock ist? Schauen Sie das bitte nochmal nach.
Wie sieht ein Rechtschenkelblock im EKG aus? In welcher Ableitung ist das vorhanden?
Das wäre auch ein Hinweis für eine Lungenembolie.
Was wäre denn noch ein Hinweis?
Welche Symptome oder welche Beschreibung der Patientin würde die Diagnose der Lungenembolie erhärten oder auch nochmal bekräftigen?
Die Patientin nimmt was ein und...
Trockene Husten.
Nein, die Therapie. Wir haben mehrere Faktoren die die Lungenembolie fördern können. Das ist zum einen die lange Reise.
Aber die Frage nach der lange Reise kam erst in der 14. Minute. Kam bei Ihnen sehr sehr spät.
Die lange Reise wäre eine der ersten Fragen. Gleich nach der 3. Minute.
Ich stelle die Frage Reiseanalyse am Ende.
Aber die Überlegung war schon richtig. Auch die Frage nach Beigenschmerzen kam sehr spät.
Und die Aussage Hormone und Zigaretten war glaube ich schon sehr wichtig, dass das eine Lungenembolie oder Thrombose sein kann.
Also lange Reise, Zigaretten und Hormone. All das stärkt die Vermutung für eine Lungenembolie.
Was ist eine Differenzialdiagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose, Epinomonie, Herzinfarkt und Gastritis vielleicht.
Das ist immer wenn man irgendwas engegefühlt in der Brust war. Das muss man immer denken.
Was ist noch Differenzialdiagnose?
Chronische Koronareherskrankheit.
Ja das haben wir schon gesagt. Herzinfarkt. Was noch? Wenn die Gefäße, wenn der Autor sehr weit ist. Was ist das?
Autosektion.
Immer natürlich. Autonesektion. Autonanorysma.
So jetzt ist die Frau Doktorin weg.
Ja bitte schön.
Wenn man eine Unterbrechen, das Gespräch, muss man nicht nur Vitalparameter anschauen, sondern auch sofort eine EKG schreiben und Sauerstoffsetigung anschauen oder?
Das sind ja Vitalparameter. Blutdruck messen.
Ich meine EKG nicht geschrieben und so weiter.
Ja das stimmt. Je nachdem. Die Patientin ist ja noch kreislaufstabil. Das heißt sie kann reden. Sie ist nicht im Schock und sie kann sich unterhalten.
Deswegen kann man da sicherlich erstmal das Gespräch führen. Wenn man natürlich den Verdacht hat, das könnte in Richtung Herzinfarkt gehen,
dann kann man natürlich neben der Sättigung und Blutdruckmessung natürlich auch gleich ein EKG schreiben.
Dann sehen sie, ob sie einen akuten Herzinfarkt hat oder nicht und können dann das Gespräch weiter fortführen. Klar.
Ist auch möglich.
Aber in der Tat, das ist schon richtig, das erste geht relativ schnell. Wenn jemand kommt und sagt, Luftnot und Engelgefühl auf der Brust,
ist eigentlich immer das erste sofort ein EKG. Kreislauf-EKG-Sauerstoffmessen.
Und kann man ohne Puls messen direkt Sauerstoff geben oder nicht?
Muss man nicht. Wenn die Patientin jetzt normal atmen kann und die Hautfarbe noch in Ordnung ist,
dann würde ich erstmal EKG schreiben und Sauerstoff-Sättigung messen. Dann kann man immer noch Sauerstoff geben natürlich.
Wenn jemand aber im Schock ist, schwer Luft bekommt und kaum reden kann, dann gebe ich als erstes natürlich Sauerstoff. Ist klar.
Es kommt sozusagen ein bisschen auf den Notfall an.
In diesem Fall müssen wir das Anamnesigespräch unterbrechen, weil unsere Patientin keine Ruhe hat.
Muss man nicht. Also sie hat keine Ruhe. Die Patientin hat extra gesagt, in Ruhe hat sie keine Beschwerden, nur bei Belastung.
Deswegen ist es, denke ich, nicht dringend notwendig, dass man sofort ein EKG schreibt oder ein Devitalparameter misst.
Aber vielleicht, also man könnte schon sagen, okay, sie haben jetzt Druck auf der Brust, sie haben Luftnot.
Wir unterbrechen das Gespräch. Wir machen ein EKG, messen Devitalparameter und machen dann weiter.
Kann man auch machen, aber muss man glaube ich jetzt in dem Fall nicht.
Aber bei Notfällen ist Zeit auch wichtig, oder? Ja, Zeit zählt.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn Sie aber eine Anamnese von 10 Minuten machen, dann haben Sie immer noch viel Zeit.
Wenn die Anamnese aber 4 Stunden dauert oder die Patientin im Krankenhaus ist, dann muss man sich natürlich schon beeilen, aber normalerweise jetzt...
Nein, ich meine, diese Patienten seit gestern haben diese Beschwerden.
Aber nicht so schlimm. Das ist richtig, aber sie war nicht so schlimm.
Sie ist ja gelaufen gekommen, sie ist stabil, sie ist bei Bewusstsein, sie redet, sie unterhält sich.
Es geht ihr relativ gut und daher ist die Situation noch nicht so schlimm.
Darf ich auch eine Frage? Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Ja, die Frau hat gesagt, ich habe bemerkt, meine Lippen sind ein bisschen blau und ich habe auch Atemnot.
Deswegen muss ich Pause...
Ja, das ist Ihre Entscheidung natürlich. Sie können dann sagen, ich unterbreche und ich messe erstmal die Devitalparameter.
Ich habe gesagt, zum Beispiel, ich muss sofort Pulsoxymeter anschauen. Sie hat gesagt, nein, ich darf nicht.
Ich erkläre, ich messe nur ein Finger an diesem Gerät.
Das ist natürlich schwierig. Das ist jetzt eine Ermessenssache, glaube ich.
Sie sind die Ärztin und Sie entscheiden, wann und wie Sie messen.
Ich meine, so ein Pulsoxy ist ja schnell gemacht. Warum soll man das nicht machen? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, ich auch.
Medizinisch gesehen haben Sie eine Aussage, relativ schnell, innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden.
Sie sehen, wie der Puls ist, wie hoch der Puls ist, ob er regelmäßig ist und wie die Sauerstoffseite ist.
Das sind wichtige Informationen. Innerhalb von fünf Sekunden. Warum soll ich das nicht machen?
Es ist doch nichts Schlimmes. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Sie da einen Wehen in Zugang legen oder die Patienten operieren oder was auch immer.
Das ist ein Pulsoxy.
Ja, das ist einfacher und also...
Im Notfall ist es das Erste, was man macht. Wenn jemand deswegen die Prüfung durchfällt, dann stimmt etwas nicht.
Okay, danke.
Eine Frage hätte ich aber an die Frau Dr. Hülya. Vielleicht müssen Sie ein bisschen für sich wissen,
also grammatikalisch, welche Zeit Sie benutzen. Ist es Präsenz, ist es Vergangenheit?
Ja, Vergangenheit.
Sie springen einmal Präsenz und dann reden Sie von Vergangenheit und dann von anderen Zeiten.
Also was ist üblich, was ist normal bei der Anamnese? Welche Zeit verwendet man?
Vergangenheit? Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ja, habe ich gemerkt.
Deshalb habe ich es falsch gemacht.
Ist es Vergangenheit oder können wir auch die Präsenz, also diese aktuelle Zeit verwenden bei der Anamnese,
indem man sagt, Patientin berichtet von Dyspnoe, sie klagt über Schmerzen.
Konjunktiv 2?
Konjunktiv 2, muss man sagen. Echt? Ich weiß nicht, was ist normal?
In der Prüfung sollen wir Konjunktiv 2 benutzen.
Haben Sie Konjunktiv 1?
1, 1.
Die blöde deutsche Grammatik.
Aber glaube ich, müssen Sie komplett oder von Anfang bis zum Ende alle Arztarzt-Gespräche nicht Konjunktiv 1 benutzen.
Ich glaube nur, wenn Sie alle Angaben mit Konjunktiv 1 berichten, bekommen Sie Schwierigkeiten oder Ärger.
Das denke ich auch. Ich denke, dass man die Präsenz, was ist nochmal Präsenz auf Deutsch?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte?
Ja.
In diesem Gespräch, um Hohmannseib zu prüfen, darf man fragen, Patientin, stellen Sie Ihre Finger oder quälen Sie Ihre Bade und haben Sie Schmerzen oder Schwierigkeiten oder nicht?
Können wir beschreiben, die Hohmannseibsachen während des Gesprächs?
Denken Sie zum Beispiel.
Ich habe die Frage leider nicht ganz verstanden.
Denken Sie, das geht?
Das geht.
Das ist gut.
Das ist ein akustischer Gespräch.
Bitte?
Wenn wir in der Anamnesik sprechen, können wir sagen, dass wir die Anamnesik in der Hand, die Beine, die Schmerzen, die Schwierigkeiten, haben?
Natürlich müssen Sie das fragen.
Wir können die Anamnesik fragen, oder?
Baldur, schnippen Sie sich die Hände und sagen, es ist eine Anamnesik.
Natürlich, ganz klar.
Das gehört hier zur Anamnesik.
Sie machen Anamnesik und gleichzeitig eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Natürlich.
Danke.
Oder hin können Sie das fragen.
Das können wir auch fragen.
Man muss ja die Symptome von der Verdacht Diagnose abfragen.
Wenn man sagt Luftnot, dann haben Sie schon im Kopf eine Idee.
Ist es das?
Ist es das Herz?
Ist es die Lunge?
Und was kann die Lunge sein?
Sie denken an Lungenembolie, also ist es vielleicht eine Thrombose?
Dann schauen Sie das Bein an und fragen natürlich nach den Symptomen einer Thrombose.
Das ist doch das Übungssystem.
Ich dachte, das gehört zur körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich darf man nicht fragen.
Ja, doch. Natürlich.
Also ich glaube, Sie sind natürlich sehr fixiert auf die Prüfung.
Und die Prüfungen sind immer sehr unterschiedlich in jedem Bundesland.
Aber als Arzt entscheiden Sie natürlich, wie Sie jemanden untersuchen.
Wie Sie jemanden eine Anamnese durchführen.
Und ob Sie gleichzeitig, normalerweise als Hausärztin, Sie sitzen ja nicht und haken Ihre Liste ab,
sondern Sie schauen die Patientin und in einer Minute haben Sie Ihre Diagnose gestellt.
Sie haben drei Fragen gestellt, haben gleichzeitig die Patienten untersucht.
Und da geht es natürlich schnell.
Weil es eine Prüfungssituation ist, muss man dann ein gewisses Schema und einen Plan durcharbeiten.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen, fällt einem schwer, komplex.
Da kommt man sich wie ein Student vor.
Aber ich denke, natürlich kann man gleichzeitig untersuchen und die Anamnese und die Fragen stellen.
Aber jetzt nochmal zu meiner Frage.
Das heißt, Sie müssen natürlich, da es gleichzeitig ein Sprachtest ist,
darauf achten, welche Grammatik, welche Zeit Sie anwenden.
Und wenn Sie ständig hin und her springen, mal Vergangenheit und dann wieder zweite Vergangenheit,
nominativ, präsent, konjunktiv, dann wird es schwierig.
Alle sind durcheinander.
Ja, das ist leider komplex und ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber mit der Zeit bekommt man sich auch ein Gefühl dafür.
Dann wird es natürlich besser.
Aber versuchen Sie immer in einer Zeit zu bleiben.
Vielen Dank für die Unterstützung.
Okay.